[Musica]
piccole scuole di montagna
due grandi strade la prima quella della
fatica la fatica di ritrovarsi in un
contesto a tratti faticoso sfidante e
per nulla comodo
l'altra strada quella di imparare fin da
subito il valore di una delle sfere che
saranno veramente importanti per tutta
la vita di un bambino e di una bambina
Fin dall'infanzia per arrivare all'età
adulta la sfera socio emotiva
relazionale si impara si impara fin dai
primi passi quando sui primi banchi di
scuola si capisce che gli altri sono una
risorsa sono un valore e perché si
capisce perché perché i genitori a loro
volta si conoscono si parlano si
confrontano e diventa importante Allora
tramite questa esperienza di imitazione
capire che le relazioni sociali sono una
risorsa un valore di fronte alla
malattia di fronte alle assenze da
scuola avere qualcuno che si prende cura
di te ti fa una telefonata ti manda un
messaggio ti passa i compiti condivide
con te una lezione Durante
tutti i lavori che magari da soli
sembrano essere pesanti noiosi difficili
avere un compagno che sta poche case più
in là anche se è difficile arrivarci
magari ci devi andare a piedi Magari ti
devi far portare nonostante questo
disagio il valore di condividere
qualcosa con qualcuno diventa permeante
diventa importante per la vita di un
bambino di una bambina Ed ecco che
allora insieme a questa relazione socio
emotiva didattica l'apprendimento
diventa Impastato di socialità di
condivisione ci si conosce per nome per
cognome genitori nonni parenti ci si
sente parte di un'intera comunità nel
bene e nel male Ecco che allora la
fatica il senso di essere isolati e di
solitudine per la gente del posto viene
proprio attutito da questi legami
sociali si generano fin dai primi banchi
di scuola
la seconda competenza quando si parla di
piccole scuole di montagna diventa
un'altra competenza che diventa utile
per tutta la vita di bambini e di
bambine che è l'organizzazione
è tutto scomodo è tutto lontano Bisogna
organizzare ogni singolo viaggio Ecco
che allora si imparerà a capire che cosa
mi serve materiale scolastico
cancelleria e Desidero vedere qualcuno
Desidero fare un lavoro nuovo un lavoro
diverso
organizzarsi e imparare a organizzarsi
diventa una priorità per non sprecare i
viaggi per arrivare ad avere tutti i
materiali pronti Ed ecco che allora ci
troviamo di fronte a bambini e bambine
in grado proprio di avere già sviluppate
fin dalla primaria e anche dalla scuola
dell'infanzia Oserei dire a tratti delle
competenze che magari in altri contesti
più urbani più cittadini sì
selezionano e si collezionano col
passare degli anni più avanti
Perché allora il valore delle piccole
scuole di montagna se dobbiamo pensare
anche al valore delle tradizioni il
valore delle tradizioni magari si
intreccia con il valore dell'Innovazione
che rappresenta davvero una sfida
importante quella di connettere le
piccole scuole di montagna con una
realtà più ampia più cosmopolita magari
Nazionale magari regionale se la sfida è
questa però dobbiamo partire da quelle
che sono già
le idee tradizionali che vogliamo
portare avanti e che fanno della nostra
comunità e del nostro territorio un
fiore all'occhiello
conoscere e recuperare lingue antiche
come il Cimbro conoscere e recuperare
tradizioni valori l'agricoltura la terra
e riuscire a portare quel valore
aggiunto anche al di fuori di quelli che
sono i contesti proprio di paese
rappresenta una sfida
essere capaci anche di riuscire a capire
il perché un territorio Come il nostro è
un territorio importante il pezzo
dedicato proprio alla pesciaia ai
fossili che magari per noi è un valore
che conosciamo e che apprezziamo ma che
sarebbe importante che fin dalla
primissima scuola dell'infanzia ci
fossero proprio laboratori dedicati
laboratori diffusi laboratori in grado
proprio di far apprezzare e conoscere Il
perché la nostra realtà È una realtà
significativa
ci troviamo di fronte quindi a pensare
anche alle risorse alle strade future
Quali potrebbero essere le strade future
per le piccole scuole di montagna se
partiamo dal bacino scientifico e
nazionale di riferimento dire
all'istituto nazionale per la ricerca
educativa in grado proprio di sapere
quali sono i punti di forza delle
piccole scuole di montagna e il perché è
importante valorizzarle tenerne conto il
fatto soprattutto di lavorare magari con
delle pluriclassi quando capita o il
fatto di fare laboratori
intergenerazionali la possibilità di
valorizzare il sapere come vi dicevo
tradizionale di nonni
e di sapere anche valorizzare il sapere
di
fiorerie aziende agricole persone che
hanno dedicato la loro vita lavorativa e
privata La valorizzazione del territorio
rappresenta un valore aggiunto da
portare avanti
inoltre
se ci trovassimo a pensare a riflettere
insieme adesso sulle strade future della
scuola soprattutto una come la nostra
che cosa pensa che cosa potremmo pensare
potremmo pensare a due grandi filoni in
mezzo a un'innovazione di Metodologia
didattica veramente molto ampia
la prima l'autore Education tradotto
educazione all'aperto ormai da una
decina d'anni il filone dell'educazione
all'aperto si rivela importante
pregnante per ciascuna realtà sia di
montagna sia urbana Ma noi possiamo
avere un valore aggiunto in più la
valorizzazione del territorio Che cos'è
l'educazione all'aperto si tratta di una
metodologia innovativa che sfrutta
l'ambiente esterno come classe e aula In
grado proprio di aprire
orizzonti ha bisogni di bambini e
bambine da un lato quindi il bisogno del
Movimento Dall'altro la gestione dello
stress Dall'altro la riscoperta del
territorio e la valorizzazione di
appunto materiali naturali in questo
caso anche archeologici geologici la
possibilità di valorizzare fin da subito
laboratori di scoperta terra
manipolazioni e impastarlo con un sapere
tradizionale Ecco che quindi un'aula
cielo aperto si rivela davvero
significativa Non solo per la scuola
dell'infanzia ma anche per la scuola
primaria ci sono già delle buone
pratiche nazionali in tutta Italia Posso
citarmene qualcuna come Bergamo Brescia
Verona a Vicenza per dire le più vicine
ma possiamo arrivare fino a Trento Roma
Palermo Torino dove piano piano le
scuole di montagna ma anche e
soprattutto le scuole di città trovano
il loro mondo e la loro dimensione nel
portare il sapere didattico tradizionale
un giorno a settimana due giorni a
settimana fuori
all'aperto in grado di valorizzare oltre
al legame insegnante bambino il terzo
Polo importante la natura e vi lascio a
una bibliografia
infinita ad andare a guardare
e fare tesoro di questo
la seconda la metodologia della
didattica aperta la didattica aperta è
importantissima per le piccole scuole di
montagna perché apro una didattica
tradizionale alla centralità dell'alunno
in grado di metterlo non solo in grado
di scegliere i tipi di apprendimento
opportuni ma anche gli spazi la
possibilità di avere un insegnante in
grado proprio di scegliere di poter fare
lezione fuori o la possibilità di avere
un insegnante che dà la possibilità di
scegliere facciamo lezione in un'aula
silenziosa o in un'aula dove si può
parlare Secondo voi Qual è la versione
migliore possiamo pensare a una
disciplina diversa piuttosto che a un
tempo diverso ma scegliamo insieme
l'autore Education quindi la didattica
aperta come metodologia innovative per
le piccole scuole di montagna abbattono
quelli che agli occhi di città o di
scuole più grosse possono essere dei
limiti quindi il numero di alunni
ridotto E soprattutto le diverse fasce
di età l'autore Educational abitativa
aperta rappresentano due sfide
metodologiche innovative in grado
proprio di mettere al centro
l'apprendimento la relazione e
soprattutto l'ambiente il contesto che
nel nostro caso Ne vale davvero la pena
intrecciare il fare scuola con l'essere
scuola partendo appunto dalla
valorizzazione di tradizioni
contesti rurali metodologie tradizionali
e metodologie innovative a seconda del
grado di scuola che con gradualità
vengono bilanciate all'interno di altre
metodologie rappresenta una risposta e
un valore aggiunto rispetto proprio a la
dimensione scolastica tradizionale
rappresenta invece un rimettere al
centro l'ambiente un rimettere al centro
il valore della natura come valore in
grado proprio di creare una sorta di
benessere educativo e socio emotivo dove
ci sia posto in modo inclusivo per tutti
e per tutte se dovessimo quindi andare
verso una conclusione di questa tipo di
Metodologia e questo tipo di sguardo
potremmo sicuramente pensare alle
piccole scuole di montagna come dei
piccoli gioielli dove si agisce fin da
subito organizzazione in grado proprio
di creare dibattiti e scambi di pensieri
di opinioni e di parole in grado di
creare anche una sorta di valore valore
aggiunto rispetto all'ambiente esterno
ambiente esterno che offre Tanto dal
punto di vista del movimento della
scoperta dell'esplorazione della
Conoscenza del territorio della
conoscenza Grazie proprio a questi
legami intergenerazionali tra nonni
bambini nipoti genitori un legame
intergenerazionale che trova senso ancor
di più con chi della natura e appunto
tutto quello che la terra offre ne ha
fatto la sua professione il suo lavoro
il perché il come e quando il chi
nonostante abbia esplorato terre lontane
sia tornato a vivere lì come può essere
visto all'interno di una scuola
Democratica come risorsa come ripartenza
come punto di vista nuovo originale e
innovativo ma soprattutto trova una
risposta grande innestando anche due
metodologie che con gradualità piano
piano possono essere scoperte adatte per
qualsiasi tipo di Panorama un panorama
che trova spazio all'interno di una
visione educativa attuale moderna ma
soprattutto rispettosa di sguardi
tradizioni saperi tramandati in modo
antico e rivisitati in chiave attuale
moderna
l'ultima parte quella dedicata alle
piccole scuole di montagna è la parte a
me più cara che è quella della
dimensione della cura
la dimensione della cura è proprio
tangibile non solo all'interno di
dimensioni di volontariato dimensione
grandissima dove la cura per i bambini
la cura per la scuola viene Donata in
modo autentico gratuito generoso perché
è importante viene vista come un valore
come un qualcosa da portare avanti in
maniera squisitamente genuina in maniera
squisitamente gratuita Quindi la forma
del dono del volontariato di persone che
donano tempo energie strumenti e
materiali alle piccole scuole di
montagna a volte passa in sottofondo in
silenzio a volte invece è giusto che
venga
importante valorizzata non come motivo
di vanto Ma come motivo di cura I care
diceva don Milani
ci tengo mi importa mi sta a cuore nelle
piccole scuole di montagna questa
versione di Don Milani trova risposta
collettiva ci interessa ci importa ci
sta a cuore la dimensione della cura
Quindi è una delle dimensioni dalle
quali ripartire e rilanciare le sfide
non solo di carattere futuro ma
soprattutto di carattere presente le
piccole scuole di montagna rappresentano
palestre di vita dal punto di vista di
competenze socio emotive organizzativo
manageriali
considerazioni storiche tradizionali di
un contesto che parla e che viene
valorizzato per quello che è stato e per
quello che potrebbe essere Quindi diamo
la possibilità ai nostri bambini alle
nostre bambine di essere riconosciuti di
avere questo senso di cura nei confronti
dell'ambiente e della scuola come
qualcosa di caro e soprattutto come
qualcosa sul quale poter investire non
solo perché fa bene a me
all'io ma perché fa bene al noi al noi
di un'intera comunità
mi interessa mi importa mi sta a cuore
Ecco che allora le piccole scuole di
montagna si trovano ad essere con le
radici dentro questa metodologia che può
andare verso sia una direzione di oggi
Education sia verso una dimensione di
Didattica aperta tenendo sempre presente
la tradizione con l'innovazione
[Musica]